potevo tutti ragazzi e me lo deve solo
video sono faringeo ci siamo tornati
subito col botto di tempo che non lo
facevo
mi sembra anche giusto ritornare agli
albori come faccio vedere che il pilota
ne hanno fatto l'update del giappone
dove hanno fatto vedere un sacco di roba
e nuove e adesso perché non avevano
messo un sacco di roba adesso sto
vedendo che non è sostanza con il
bellissimo
proveremo a fare un bel pole in giappone
dopo però quello che andremo a fare per
il titolo che avete visto al dialetto
proveremo a vedere com'è fatta chernobyl
visto che molti voli hanno chiesto nei
commenti ma facendo che abbiamo l'aereo
giusto vice ivo la teoricamente dovrebbe
essere giusto ragazzi google maps che
non è che stoffa chissà che cosa
teoricamente speriamo ci avrei arrivare
allo ragazzi siamo sul nostro bellissimo
assist
era un po che non può lavorare quindi un
attimo migliori figlia non dove che
stiamo andando chernobyl più o meno ai
linea d'aria è qua qua in questo punto
teoricamente se io sono volo questo
punto dovremmo farlo però anche ad
atterrare se riesco adesso vediamo
intanto siamo il popolo siamo giusti
teoricamente se vadano quanto perde che
c'è che figo dio santo benedetto
ma che succede stai calmo ragazzi io
l'ho vista solo in call of duty
chernobyl perché c'è stata in tante
missioni però vediamo se riesco a fare
il punto giusto mentre voliamo scenderei
un attimo di quadrini quota perché
secondo me possiamo godere
5 in più il paesaggio chernobyl jano
potrai seguire il fiume il network
qualunque e questo lo ha fatto gli
alieni ragazzi ma che razza di roba è
così ecco cosa cosa mi rappresenta
allora ragazzi siamo in dirittura
d'arrivo tolgo cioè diminuisco la
velocità del motore mi abbasso perché
teoricamente dovrei riuscire a sorvolare
chernobyl allora chernobyl è esattamente
il luogo dove sto per passare in questo
istante
quindi questo questa cittadina qua che
vedete è teoricamente ma anche
praticamente chernobyl qui io vado lento
lento lento lento
siamo arrivati è piano lo zio piano
piano piano piano piano
perfetto vado vado di sotto più lento
possibile per godersi il paesaggio
poi passeremo sul lago raga quindi
questo e chernobyl non hanno fatto la
ruota panoramica quella abbandonata
quella delle foto però questa è certo
che siamo su chernobyl 100 100 proprio
c'è una nave abbandonata là va bene c'è
roba abbandona pensa questi che vivevano
in mezzo all'isola proprio di cernobbio
miso la fighissimo e poi dall'altra
parte del lago troviamo il reattore
ci sono delle mafie ciao ragazzi tu stai
andando un po fuori strada vedono quasi
più ma occhio che vi schiantate occhio
siete spazzati a tanto così rega occhio
guidare che non è uno scherzo erno villa
abbiamo vista è quella lì quindi
l'abbiamo dato che se facciamo tutto il
percorso sul lago per arrivare al
reattore che si trova apripista
ho letto su google maps e voi non so se
man detto cazzate non rispondo di cagate
abbia andiamo hanno diviso il lago era
già così all hanno fatto loro
dovrei iniziare a diminuire la velocità
un po prima perché già vedo punto i
ladri numero cinque ragazzi è
praticamente qua qua questo questo
quadro è anche il rilievo l'anno fattori
è questo qua ragazzi l'hanno fatto in
rilievo l'hanno fatto dettagliata
attenzione adesso mi abbasso e vediamo
questo lo hanno fatto più dettagliato
già lo vedo
poi c'è una distorsione per pratiche che
ci restano
o qualcosa che non ha caricato c della
distruzione
qua vedo qualcosa in rilievo era quindi
vado
quello al reattore 3
no
come si era arrivato più lento vado più
lento per vedere se riesco a godermi il
paesaggio di più
avaya bassa e l'engine a del suo ok
teoricamente ci dovremmo essere ai
ragazzi se vado abbastanza lento
rallenta rallenta zio è una velocità
esagerata ancora pensavo di diminuirla
molto più facilmente ma va beh eccoci
qua allora qua c'è roba strana che non
capisco e signore e signori questo
dovrebbe essere il punto del reato
questo quando stiamo adesso non capisco
questa roba che anche prima non si
capiva
questo e chernobyl
veramente non è chernobyl dove c'è
andato è veramente strano perché ve le
immaginate un po più desolato invece no
c'erano ma che roba non so adesso però
madonna avviso connessione pensa a cosa
connessione tendente che aiuto
connessione persa qualcosa con l'aereo e
che cazzo è successo perché sopra
chernobyl perdo la connessione è vero
che è successo calmi ok siamo passati in
connessione riuscita sono appena sono
uscito l'arma come ma non puoi
connetterti con internet falsi sono a
chernobyl farvi capire qual è il
problema
se fossi sopra relatore va bene avendo
una cittadina non solo la cella i
ragazzi pro prova a vedere se riesco ad
atterrare nei pressi della città che
pure molto più vicino a questa queste
preprint che se propri piani
quindi abbiamo lenti però non troppo
perché ci passo vicino quando vrebbero
esserci insomma le case abbandonate un
ritorno
ma il violento zio perfetto non sembra
abbandonato dalla flight simulator prova
per ricordiamoci che tra il seguito
ragazzi un simulatore cioè cerca di
riportare la realtà ma comunque
ragazzina figata ma che roba
però vedere se riesco ad atterrare alle
sole non so dove l'altro non mi dicono
che si mette giù il carrello un carrello
dove lo metto giù hanno messo giù non so
come non so cosa ho fatto
non so cosa schiacciato però non è
andato giù cosa terrestre edificio
consentirà di superare la tua bottio
dovreste casa e poi a terra poi prima
supera le case poi a terra prima nessun
pero e poi atterro te lo giuro io ho
capito un oggetto provocato grandi live
aveva e non fa niente non era messa
proprio bene come come tratta per ora i
my friends and let the part forse doppio
che sta qua
vediamo se riesco a fare una partita né
da in realtà io quando vado a tokyo
ragazzi a terra sempre cioè parto
fondato una casa è atteso sempre
annarita che è molto fuori totti invece
anedda che proprio all aeroporto che sta
provocatorio ragazzi lei quella che sta
padana che figo anche il ponte in tre
tutto in 3d finissimo quello che state
vedendo comunque
la città degli sfondi vuole vorrei
veramente liberati o magari che ragioni
che mi trasferirò in giappone arriverà
il giorno ben altra cosa o morto
però il mio sogno rimane questo ragazzi
chi si trasferisce con me qua c'è una
superstrada allora teoricamente tokyo la
tokyo tower rack dovrebbe essere quale
il dolce non qui dove sono i questo
momento ma dovrebbe comunque vedersi se
non si vede perché proprio non è
caricata non è che dal suo sbagliando al
posto di quello di questo sono convinto
quindi non me la mensa
vabbè ma chissenefrega tanto è comunque
rapid ho dato che oggi però la tokyo
tower è una delle mete dove ovviamente
un fisico sempre perché l'enel
contentissimo però per adesso andiamo di
qua o forse forse ho mai drive non aver
agazzi ciao ragazzi non ci parliamo
ma proprio lui ma proprio il pilota
dumber one da maraga ormai certo giorno
non ha segreti
ma neanche gta non so dove atterrare
scendiamo perché parte prova atterrare
sul fiume teoricamente non dovrebbe
andar via fuocolare 1 all'aeromobile è
finito il fiume ma basta ma mi piace per
il culo comunità verità ma cosa ma cosa
come con qualche cosa c'è una strada di
trattazione di fido mi fido
dell'architettura giapponese e pro
vedere se è finita la strada non è che
io vivo dei confini ma non ho abbastanza
spazio laterale mai nella vita raga non
so non so dove atterrare ci provo il
favi favi ci prova
ma no ho peccato solo un albero vabbè ma
che vuoi che sia capito grazie di averci
seguito fino a partite dal canale
lasciato il commento se volete un
consiglio sono il prossimo viaggio da
fare
come sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
io e le ragazze
[Musica]
no